let's try something different today
let's play cards
this is a standard deck of cards as you
can see I'm finished early and that's a
good for their cards can you tell me
when you want me to stop easy sir
let me see it everyone okay
here is your card
yeah it's not a car do you think DC
Circuit do you think so everyone's like
you read yeah no way what else our car
now I can tell me you don't need to know
a magic trick to create a magical
presentation you just need to know a few
tricks on how to contrast the delivery
from the book resonate Nancy Duarte
talks about three ways on how to
contrast the delivery using stage style
and interaction let's start with the
stage we think about the front of the
room however there are many different
areas to the room most of the time we
have individuals stand in the front of
the room and they're the main event the
sole focus is on them as the presenter
and they sometimes will even hide behind
the podium as they give their
presentation they'll use the stage as it
is whether it's the podium or perhaps
standing solely by a microphone in the
center of the room this can be
appropriate in certain scenarios it can
be expected or even required you're
giving a conference presentation they've
told you to stand behind the podium or
there's a norm around formality we
encourage though as is recommended in
Nancy Duarte stuck to mix some of these
traditional elements with some
unexpected
Thanks such as perhaps sharing the main
event as Ricardo did when doing his
magic trick taking the spotlight
perhaps away from himself over to an
audience member in the meantime also
don't be afraid to roam there can be
some comfort in standing behind a podium
but there's also opportunities either to
enter the room as I did from another
area or roaming and engaging with other
audience members as JD and Bert do so
effectively during the classroom setting
there's also opportunities to use the
stage more as a setting so that can be
rather than standing on one location
perhaps pulling up a chair to have a Q&A
using something more informally to have
that kind of conversation topic and with
that I'll pass it over to Prithvi to
talk about style as a way to really
engage your audience Explorer I'd like
to start by reading a short excerpt from
my midterm the prudent investor should
strive to avoid actively managed mutual
funds as these tends tend to perform in
line with the market over the long term
in spite of much advertisement to the
contrary because of this net fourth
amuse 75 basis points were say anything
could be achieved by investing in said
and low-cost index funds I hope you
agree that was pretty boring there's a
couple reasons for that one is it's
about index funds which I personally
find fascinating but judging for my
midterm feedback very few of you share
that opinion but one of the other
reasons is the style that I protected
that way so I did a couple things I
tried to have a serious business tone I
think I actually had a monotone I looked
at my paper there was a ton of jargon it
just wasn't that interesting now there's
a time and a place for that sometimes
your subject is so serious that you need
to use a certain type of language
sometimes you need to use jargon to
build your credibility but today we're
here to argue that it makes sense to mix
traditional
and conversational elements by adding
humor and other things you do in
everyday conversation you'll find that
your audience is much more engaged in
the content that you want them to get
now you have some examples of formal
style on the left side of the slide we
do it all the time of business school
and so today I'm gonna focus on adding
conversational style to your content
Nancy Duarte has a couple of tips but
it's the Friday before Thanksgiving and
so I'm gonna make it even simpler
there's one thing you need to remember
dialogue not monologue well I mean by
that we all enjoy talking to her friends
much more than we do giving a speech in
front of a large group of people so the
next time you have a speech to give
don't start by writing start by talking
about it with one of your close friends
and afterwards reflect on what worked
and what didn't work what points were
you able to get across what point did
you wish that you had tried after that
start writing and I think you'll find
that that approach makes you more
relaxed makes your buy language more
energetic and makes your audience feel
more invited but talk is cheap and talk
about conversation is probably really
cheap so I'm going to try this so on the
left side of this slide is the paragraph
that I just read in case you wanted to
relive and here's here's the trynna the
conversation llama every holiday season
Bud Light comes out with a special
holiday can sometimes it has a Christmas
tree maybe some Holly I think there's a
49ers logo now imagine that that can of
beer cost you $15 five times as much for
the same can just with a fancier
wrapping you wouldn't buy that candy
beer well an actively managed mutual
fund is the same thing it's the same
product with a fancier wrapping you
wouldn't overpay for your beer don't
overpay for your investments that was a
little bit more convincing so I use
humor and an analogy there we do those
things all the time in conversation
we don't always remember to do them in
speeches the next time you have a big
speech have a conversation first and
you'll find that your eyes is engaged
enough to remember your content
so before we move on to my section show
fans who thought Laura's entrance was
dramatic and added impact to the
presentation
it's almost everyone except the person
with the camera he is not excited what
about when we did his two different
delivery styles would someone like to
share why they thought one of them was
better than the other you got to hear a
story excellent and that's using stuck
different delivery styles and by using
all parts of the stage you're able to
bring in more impact to your
presentation I'm here to talk about one
other technique that Nancy Duarte
advises to encourage to increase your
impact to the presentation one of the
biggest fears that a presenter has when
they're coming up on stage and standing
in front of you other than forgetting
lines is losing their audience to
boredom some they wander off into a
daydream for example it's very hard to
bring them back into your presentation
the key to grabbing the attention of
your audience and keeping it with you is
to make sure that you involve them right
away and how do you involve them by
interacting with them frequently a
traditional presentation involves
minimizing disruption resisting live
feedback and sometimes even requesting
silence we've been in many talks where
the presenter starts asking for a
silence but just as pretty and Laura put
it there are times when this is really
important where you don't take away the
experience of the audience by putting in
disruptions into your presentation but
there are also many opportunities where
you can enhance the experience of the
audience by adding in elements of
interaction how do you do this three
techniques that Nancy Duarte recommends
number one plan your own disruptions
you can do that by calling for a vote
you can do that by setting up icebreaker
exercises in the beginning of classes or
presentations or you can do it by you
can do it by I'm drawing a blank here
but you can do it by many other methods
but you also need to embrace real-time
feedback into your presentation Niro did
it by going into the audience
seeking live feedback and then bringing
it into his presentation when you saw
the card that you found out on the
screen up there it feels like you're
involved with the presentation a little
more then if you're just seeing a talk
you also seek to encourage exchanges
between audience that's what I try to do
at the beginning I asked you a question
and you're able to give me an answer
which I then was able to if I agreed
build up on it or if I disagree gives me
a chance to refute that and and cover
that as well so we're able to do this
incorporate elements of contrast using
sage style and interaction to make your
presentation more impactful
you